justin bruhl he'll make his second start
of the series the left-hander pitched
just an inning a couple of days ago as
an opener and that's how he's going to
operate again here tonight hoy park the
shortstop leading off 231 hitter
and it's now a 2-2 count justin turner
will
shift over to the right side of the
infield closest to second base gavin lux
in between
turner and muncie with seeger on the
left side by himself swinging a miss
strike three another cutter
hoy park swung could not connect and
that's the first strikeout of the ball
game and that's how things begin tonight
for the opener justin brewer the pirates
trying to leave here with a win so
tonight they're going to go with jt
brubacher he's four and 12 with a 513
era the right-hander man on for max
muncie
right about it a 35 home run pace which
is the number that he had in 2018 and
19.
of course that run interrupted by the
short season last
one the other year
[Music]
back it goes
number 27
opposite field home run for muncie and
the dodgers strike in the first
muncie home run number 27 and the
dodgers strike first it's two nothing
already up two nothing turner at second
for seeger
two doubles in last night's game and
goes after the first one here joins the
hit parade with a base hit to right
polanco's throw is up the line and just
like that it's three nothing
white is over nine in the big leagues
and he's over ten in the big leagues
first strikeout for brubaker who is now
retired five in a row pollux started the
game with a single
came into score on muncie's home run
reaches out here sends it in the air to
deep center field reynolds out of room
it's gone
home run aj pilot can they lead four
nothing
aj pollock with his 15th home run of the
year
dodgers four pirates nothing as a.j
rounds the bases
he's two for two tonight
27 homers 72 rbis for muncie
here's the pitch strength three call
fastball up and in in the zone
muncie is gone and so are the dodgers
but pollock homers to center
it's four to nothing la as we go to the
third seeger lefty matter
they got the right side covered with
three men
here's the righties o2
strike three call
coming to 93 up and in
but it gets the call and there's one out
now will smith will come up
four nothing dodgers here in the third
inning will smith is a catcher from the
university of louisville
here's the pitch and a swing and a miss
cody ballinger is all for one he popped
up to wilmer defoe in the first inning
so one on two out four nothing dodgers
here's the 2-2 swing and a miss
bellinger big cut and three strikeouts
in a row for brubacher after the lead
off one
brian reynolds over one he bounced out
to max muncie at first base in the first
inning
mitch wines and sends one home and
there's a shot right toward justin
turner in the shift he lays out for it
makes the grab
and for the second inning in a row
mitch white has set the side down in
order one two three go the pirates
middle of the fourth dodgers four
pirates nothing here's gavin lux
he fell out to hayes back in the second
inning
here's the old one and swinging a busted
bat liner caught
in the heel of the glove by moran that's
the second out i was wondering if the
the ground would jar it loose but he was
able to hold on white went down swinging
his first time it's one of the five for
brubacher how about that mitch white
draws the first jt blue banker walk
better partners second but either way
it's a walk for mitch white
sometimes you get up to the bat
roll your sleeves up you show off your
guns and you can intimidate
first time reaching base is a big
leaguer
welcome to first
it's not a hitch he don't you don't get
the baseball for that yeah
i reached base give me the baseball
you're not allowed to give me the
baseball for a walk you don't do that
i'm going to take the basement that's
what i'm thinking i'm like
take the base and the dodgers now with
two on and two out for max muncie two on
two out and a payoff pitch coming
there they go here it comes muncie hits
one in the air deep right field polanco
back on the track it is gone again
muncie goes deep for the second time
some mvp chance for max muncie a
three-run home run for muncie
in his second
two home run game this week how do you
like that
boy is maxwell swinging the silver
hammer
that's now 28 home runs allowed by
brubacher this year so most home runs
ever
allowed by a pirates pitcher in his
first 22 starts of the season
corey seger is one for two of the run
batted in tonight and he is up again
here's the o2
and seeger cannot hold up he's down on
strikes we'll go to the fifth it's the
dodger seven and the pirates nothing
and mitch white the relief pitcher gets
his third plate appearance of the night
here's the o2 and a swing and a miss he
struck him out
two walks two left will go to the sixth
and there are two gone in the sixth
cory sieger coming back up he's one for
three struck out twice
seeger struck out looking in the third
swinging in the fourth had an rbi single
in the first
hitting 284 five home runs for seeger
seeger flies on the left center field to
go back it's gone
fourth home run of the night for the
dodgers the route is on at nine nothing
a home run corey seeger a two run shot
and the dodgers lead it nine to nothing
ninth spot in the batting order due up
and you'll see kevin newman
coming up to pinch-hit
right-handed batter
started at shortstop last night so
newman will pinch it in the eighth
newman a 226 hitter three home runs he's
driven in 26.
he swings and rifles one right at
seeger who moved to his left and stabbed
it for the out boy that was a missile
off the bat of newman but seeger right
there to make the play and the side
retire
halfway through the eighth inning
tonight it's the dodgers nine pittsburgh
numbers and now the pirates down to
their final out here's colin moran who
is singled twice tonight once against
white back in the fifth
little dribbler along third smith the
first that's it what a performance from
mitch white
seven and a third to finish the game
you look at the score you got nine
nothing for the dodgers the offense
definitely did their job